esos departamentos incluyen el de la
ciudad de parís pero también varios del
norte de francia y en la costa
mediterránea el departamento que incluye
a niza en esos lugares a partir de ahora
las personas para desplazarse ya sea
pedir al médico hacer las compras e
incluso para hacer deportes van a
necesitar de un permiso pero ojo sin
limitación horaria y podrán alejarse
hasta 10 kilómetros de sus hogares los
comercios no esenciales estarán cerrados
en esos departamentos solo abrirán los
esenciales entre ellos también las
librerías y las disquerías las escuelas
elementales y los colegios que reciben
hasta niños de 11 años seguirán abiertos
en cambio los liceos de educación
secundaria solamente van a recibir a un
50% del alumnado las universidades van a
seguir como hasta ahora esto es una
parte de clases a distancia y otra
presencial el primer ministro de rne
castells llamó a las empresas y
administraciones a privilegiar el
trabajo a distancia al menos cuatro de
cinco días a la semana recordó también
que los viajes entre regiones están
prohibidos salvo por motivos imperiosos
y que
el resto de los departamentos tendrá el
toque de queda ahora a partir de una
hora más tarde comenzará a las 7 de la
tarde en vista del pronto cambio al
horario de verano y además explicó el
primer ministro que a partir de mañana
serán retomadas las inoculaciones con la
vacuna de astrazéneca después de que hoy
la agencia europea del medicamento
considerara que es un antígeno seguro y
eficaz